aquí en teherán nos reunimos como hama
marandi que es asesor del gobierno en
estas negociaciones nucleares y le
preguntamos cuál era de sus puntos que
son importantes para teherán para volver
a revivir este acuerdo y si tenía que
ver con el asunto de levantar las
sanciones contra los guardianes
revolucionarios como argumenta
washington
los estadounidenses a través de los
medios y centros de pensamiento aseguran
que el asunto son los guardias que están
en la lista de terroristas de los eeuu
en respuesta dijo que si washington
remueve a esta organización de la lista
hoy todavía no habría acuerdo porque
para irán ese no es el asunto principal
el asunto principal son las garantías de
que eeuu no traicionará a irán de nuevo
como ya lo hizo en 2015 irán busca la
implementación del acuerdo e irá no
quiere que esas garantías sean puestas
en su lugar para que los estadounidenses
simplemente no puedan destruir el
acuerdo de nuevo e irse
teherán siempre ha dicho que la
condición principal para volver al
acuerdo nuclear es beneficiarse
económicamente y que se levante en la
totalidad de las sanciones sin embargo
los críticos del gobierno radical en
teherán acusan de estar torpedeando
volver a este acuerdo y no querer
realmente volver a hacerlo le
preguntamos al profesor marandi cuáles
son las condiciones en teherán en este
momento y cómo ven la situación global
actualmente
hay que tener en cuenta que el mundo
está cambiando irán está vendiendo su
petróleo y a muy alto precio irán no
tiene petróleo suficiente para
satisfacer la demanda de sus clientes la
relación entre irán y rusia ha mejorado
los rusos necesitan a iran la relación
con china también ha mejorado los
europeos han reconocido que necesitan el
acuerdo no hay petróleo adicional en el
mercado como macrón le dijo a bailén es
así como los estadounidenses y europeos
necesitan un acuerdo e irán no pide nada
extraordinario lo que pide es la total
implementación del acuerdo firmado en
2015 y la confirmación de que eeuu no
traicionará nuevamente a irán
la delegación iraní ha dicho que seguirá
en contacto con la unión europea para
seguir conversando sobre este acuerdo
sin embargo no hay ninguna fecha para
próximas conversaciones lo que ha hecho
que el real la moneda local en irán
caiga nuevamente frente al dólar y que
el pesimismo vuelva a imperar en las
calles de la ciudad